what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I'm going to make you guys an
expert on Ezekiel Sims because he is
seemingly the main villain in The Madam
Webb film based on the trailer although
I think by the end of this video you'll
start to think like I do which is that
Ezekiel Sims is a red herring and that
the movie is going to tie together
everything from Spider-Man the video
game into the spiderverse movie probably
Tom Halland Spider-Man the whole nine
yards so Ezekiel Sims first appeared in
Amazing Spider-Man Volume 2 issue number
30 and he was introduced in a way that
basically one revealed that he knew who
Peter Parker was two he has the same
Powers as Spider-Man and three he
actually blew Spiderman's wig off
because he asked him this question right
he said how did you get your powers
right and Peter simply said he was
bitten by a radioactive spider the
response of Ezekiel Sims is so here's
what's going to blow your mind how do
you know that it was the radioactivity
of the spider that gave you your powers
or was it simply that you got your
powers from the spider bite and the
radioactivity was irrelevant totally
changed the Spider-Man Mythos because in
Amazing Spider-Man Volume 2 issue number
32 we end up getting what is kind of the
origin of Ezekiel Sims although it's not
really in death it's more that he just
kind of got his powers while he was out
exploring and got his powers from an
external Source we didn't really get the
ends and outs of it and even to this day
I don't think we've genuinely gotten a
full-on origin for Ezekiel Sims although
I may be incorrect in that but what it
also does is it ties in one the idea of
the spider totems and that two morun is
hunting for Peter Parker and what ends
up happening is Ezekiel Sims basically
presents Peter with a room that he can
stay in until the threat is neutralized
or seemingly for the rest of his life
potentially and it'll keep him protected
from Moran and the inheritors or
if you want to call him that so how does
all that tie together okay now we'll
talk about why the inheritors and merlon
and all that matter here in a second but
one thing I do want to explain is that
an Amazing Spider-Man Volume 3 issue
number four is part of Marvel's original
sin event which was basically this kind
of huge revelation of all these things
that people just didn't realize about
their own lives or things that had taken
place in their lives uh during this
comic we end up learning that there was
a girl named Cindy Moon who was
basically bitten by the same radioactive
spider that bit Peter and that she ended
up gaining spider powers as a result the
kicker about all this is she was
successfully sealed away in a room by
Ezekiel Sims where Spider-Man had turned
down the offer and that's why we had
never seen her after that point because
she was quite literally locked in a room
somewhere she ended up coming out and of
course became a major player in the
Spiderman Mythos and her and Peter just
couldn't stop banging like literally
they could not keep their hands off each
other but to tie in the idea of the
spider totems Mor Lun the inheritors all
that kind of stuff this is where I think
the movie is going in terms of direction
right so the idea behind this is that
Spider-Man as you know him did not
simply just get his powers from a
radioactive spider that's not really
where it came from that when Spider-Man
received a bite from the radioactive
spider it tied him into a grander mytha
that was actually created by a
particular Goddess that we didn't know
about until we got to like edge of
spiderverse volume 2 or volume 3 but the
thing about this is that with him having
a bite from a radioactive spider anyone
across the Multiverse who is bitten by a
radioactive spider gets tied into
something called the web of life and
Destiny so to explain this whole idea of
like morun the inheritors the totems all
that kind of stuff the way this all ties
together is that much like what we
mentioned a second ago Peter Parker as
you know him did not simply just get his
powers from a radioactive spider he was
actually selected by What's called the
Great Weaver and the great Weaver
basically holds on to and monitors
What's called the web of life and
Destiny this is almost kind of like the
force from Star Wars right except it
only applies to people who are
Spider-Man or spiderwomen from across
the Multiverse and it ties them all
together it's kind of the thread that
runs through all of them but every
Universe has a version of like the Scion
or the bride or the other or something
like that that those are just names
given to the various avatars that are
out there for example the gatekeeper
according to Amazing Spider-Man issue
number 506 is responsible for
controlling mystical forces right
exactly what that means is relative to
the story The Bride of who of course is
Cindy moon in the main Marvel Universe
she's responsible for individuals who
gain their spider powers by chance right
so Peter Parker happening to be at the
science exhibit and the radioactive
spider just happening to be there and
then coming down you could argue it was
Destiny or you could argue it was ch
whatever the case happens to be that's
what Cindy Moon represents so each one
of them represents a kind of concept
within how it is that an individual can
become a Spider-Man or a Spider Woman
but with Moran and the inheritors these
are basically a group that just traveled
through the Multiverse and hunted
Spider-Man and Spider women everywhere
they could find them and the reason for
this is actually pretty simple right so
when it comes to like these spider
totems they exist as kind of like this
almost mythical Animal Kingdom type
thing right so that's why like in the
comics for example Mor Lun went to
wakanda and tried to attack Black
Panther and then got his ass handed to
him so the thing to know here is that
they feed on spiders because that gives
them the most amount of energy and
honestly according to them it tastes the
most delicious right so it's like why we
all like ribey instead of tone steaks or
like New York strips right because they
just taste the
best but with the Multiverse itself the
inheritors travel throughout every
single universe and kill every version
of Spider-Man or Spiderwoman than they
can possibly find and so that's likely
what's going on in this film that
Ezekiel Sims is a red herring and that
the the role of Ezekiel Sims is actually
going to turn out to be something akin
to a mentor that his role is going to be
to show up to Madam web and say actually
you know I'm going to pull a Nick Fury
here and say that you're part of a much
bigger Universe you just didn't know
about it right and like that's it and
then what it's going to do is it's going
to introduce the spider verse which is
the full collection of every version of
Spider-Man and Spiderwoman from across
the Multiverse and tie them all together
the PlayStation Spider-Man like Miles
Morales from into the spiderverse any
other versions of Spider-Man that we see
there uh probably Tom Holland Spider-Man
maybe Andrew Garfield maybe Toby McGuire
not entirely sure I don't know where
Sony's going to go with it but that's
kind of the nature of Ezekiel Sims I
know we sidetracked here for a second
but the role of Ezekiel Sims in Marvel
Comics was more as a mentor to Peter
Parker kind of teaching him the true
nature of his powers but also a way for
Marvel to segue into this idea that
there's much more to the entire Mythos
of Spider-Man and spiderwomen in Marvel
Comics they simply just being bitten by
a radioactive spider and like that was
it so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end uh if you
guys are interested in learning more
about Spider-Man spider totems a whole n
yards make sure you click this link to
the playlist it'll take you to our whole
Spider-Man playlist where we cover
everything and uh we'll catch you all
later peace